Okay.
Well,
since we haven't been at this for
awhile,
I'm going to briefly review what we've
come up to him and then where are we
going?
Okay.
I guess the basic idea,
well,
maybe I'll start with something instead.
I guess we probably reviewed enough.
I'm going to read you something from
Tolstoy,
which you probably read or theoretically
read.
One of the things we're going to discuss
today please,
the manner in which anomalous
information,
because that's itself,
the different manners in which anomalous
information can present itself and how
that,
how anomalous information as a category
is represented.
Basically.
No,
we know already.
Anomalous inflammation tends to adopt
symbolism associated with the feminine
feminine with chaos because it's a
normal information,
which is information you don't expect.
Of course,
that produces emotional chaos because it
disrupts your versions of the emotional
significance of the present and the
future and conceivably how to get from
one to the other.
Our whole discussion so far has been
based on the idea that you can look at
the world from two different
perspectives and when you're thinking
about the constituent elements of
things,
you can take the straight materialistic
perspective,
which is a perfectly reasonable thing to
do.
And talk about how things are
constructed scientifically as if they're
independent object and we've got a long
way it's doing that.
But there's another way that you can
look at the world and that's as a place
that exists as experience and as a place
that exists as a stage for action
basically.
And it is the case,
I think it's,
it's well known and not frequently
disputed that the world as a place to
act is not derived bubble as from the
world as it exists,
which is to say that you can accumulate
all the facts you want about a given
situation or a thing.
And that doesn't tell you how you,
how you should conduct your behavior in
that situation or around that thing.
And the reason for that basically is
because you have to choose,
you'd have to make decisions about what
constitutes the optimal solution to your
particular emotional problems.
Yes,
and I,
I said before and I've been thinking
about this a lot lately,
I think one of the reasons that
average before,
oh,
the nonacademic community has contempt
for the academic community is because we
have been laboring under the presumption
that
knowing facts is,
is what intelligence is for and that's
not right.
Intelligence is to tell you how to
regulate your emotions.
That's what it's for.
Can you do that by figuring out how to
behave?
If you've explored something thoroughly
from this perspective,
that means that you know how to act when
you're there.
It doesn't mean you know everything
about the situation from the factual
perspective,
and that's obvious because you'll never
find yourself in a situation where you
know everything from the factual
perspective.
And that brings up another interesting
point,
which is
how is it that you can stop asking
questions since you're always surrounded
by an infinite number of mysteries and
answer to that is as far as I can tell
it,
you stop asking the questions about a
situation when what you know is good
enough to get you where you want to be
in that situation.
And that constitutes grounds for
presuming that your exploratory behavior
in that situation has gone far enough.
So if I want something from you,
despite the fact that I don't know
everything about you or even anywhere
near anything and everything about you,
I know you sufficiently when my
interactions with you produce the
results that I did,
I did,
I desire.
And so that gives us some insight into
how it is that your knowledge can both
be limited but sufficient.
And that's a useful,
that's a useful piece of information to
have.
You're to explored territory when what
you do produces what you want.
And the,
from the mythological perspective,
explored territory is one of the
constituent elements of the universe,
right?
That's the no,
that's the patriarchal system.
How unexplored territory,
whenever something you do produce as a
consequence,
you don't expect.
And that's,
that's an interesting notion because we
tend to think of territory as the place
that you're at.
But this is in a sense a way of making a
leaf up into the idea of a spiritual
territory.
Because psychologically speaking,
you can be in the
psychologically speaking,
despite the fact that you're in the same
place.
You can be in two different places.
If,
sorry,
let me get this straight.
Even though even if I don't shift
position,
I can be in two different places.
If I'm talking to you and what I want to
happen happens,
that's one place.
And if I'm talking to you and something
or don't expect happens,
that's another place.
Even though I haven't moved,
the emotional significance of those two
places is entirely different.
So those are psychological places and as
far as myth,
mythology is concerned,
it's psychological places that are real.
That's at least with regards to their
significance for behavior,
which is what myth is concerned with.
Genomic was concerned with morality.
That's,
that's normal.
That's not names.
All right,
so there's the place that you're
familiar with and that's the place that
you've explored sufficiently so that
what you want to happen is happening and
there's a place that you're unfamiliar
with and that's the place that emerges
when you make a mistake.
And then there's the process that turns
one into the other,
which is to say that if you make a
mistake and you continue to explore,
you might be able to modify your
behavior so that the consequences of
your mistake vanish,
which basically means that you can
figure out how you should have behaved
in that circumstance and that you
rectify your behavior in the future or
that you can smooth things over so that
the consequences of your mistake go away
now.
So that's the capacity to turn chaos in
doored.
It's also the case that you can turn
order into chaos
by continuing to explore in territory
that other people have already defined
as sufficiently explored.
And that means that the process of
creative exploration can bring order and
it can also bring chaos.
These are forms of the normally here.
Okay.
They're written down in the,
in the manuscript.
The revolutionary hero as a bringer of a
normally is someone who continues to
explore.
When everyone else says we're getting
where we want to be at the present time,
which is just to say they're saying you
should leave
well enough alone.
All right.
One of the things that we've been trying
to do,
we looked at mythological
representations of the unknown and they
tend to take two forms.
Basically,
they tend to manifest themselves in
feminine shape and there's a lot of
reasons for that,
but the basic reason is because
it's the unknown that everything comes
from.
So when you explore something unknown,
you generate new information.
So it's reasonable to conceive of the
unknown as a matrix.
And the idea of the Matrix is
contaminated cognitively speaking with
quick notions of creation and notions of
the source.
And it's reasonable to think of the
unknown as the source of all things.
It's reasonable as a consequence,
I think of it hasn't in the same
category as feminine things.
And the unknown takes the unknown as a
feminine thing takes on two sets of
characteristics and one is the creative
characteristics and the other is the
destructive characteristics because the
unknown can disrupt things and destroy
them and it,
but it also serves as the ground for
everything.
So it has it affectively ambivalent
status that's permanent.
So that's a constituent element of
experienced on don't always have to
structure.
It frightens you and it makes you
hopeful and it does both of those
simultaneously and that puts you into a
state of interest.
I get conflict,
so which,
which has really nothing to do with
your,
your psychological state as an
individual.
It basically means that no matter who
you are,
if you encounter something I'm known
those two sets of emotions are going to
be generated.
And then the other thing we tried to do
was to think about how the gnome itself
is structured and that brought us to
this idea
which which is in its sort of elaborated
form,
which is that
if you know where you're at and what
you're doing,
it means that you have a stable view of
who you are.
And also where you're going and and also
how to get there and that's all one
thing.
That's one story,
but you're cooperating with someone and
you're doing something.
Then your story shared,
you've hammered out your differences and
you have to find a territory that's
founded basically where almost nothing
unpredictable it can happen.
One of the things we tried to do was to
figure out how
while the simple one was the,
yeah,
been a theory about where you want to go
and the theory about where you are and
you have a series of plans to get from
one to the other.
But we also have discussed the fact that
the plans themselves are actually
theories of the same sword.
So
that diagram presents what are basically
nested stories.
It's like you're a small ambitions are
nested in your bigger ambitions.
You take,
do you come to a class to graduate from
the class to graduate from the class in
order to get your degree in order to
pursue your career,
your career as part of your duties as a
citizen,
so on and so forth.
So the stories and to become nested in
one another and this nesting also has
the form of a dominance hierarchy
because
if we're engaged in a dominance dispute,
what that basically means is that we're
arguing about whose stories could occupy
a superordinate position.
That's one way of looking at it.
We might also both the arguing in order
to construct the third story that we can
both agree to,
but that doesn't happen very often if
it's sort of a brute force dominant,
struggled at it.
Just whoever has the most effective
argument,
the tools at hand,
which could also involve physical force.
When I was writing my story takes
precedence or at least in this
situation,
oh,
that's a dominance hierarchy and
the known which is explored territory.
It's also equivalent to culture is
constructed of the Internet of sequences
of internets.
That stories that have been arranged in
terms of the relative importance over
spans thousands and thousands of years.
And one of the things we've been trying
to do is to figure out,
well if you're,
if you're in the same culture as someone
else,
that means that you share at least a
certain set of stories with that person.
And we've been trying to figure out is
one of those stories consist of and also
what might be the most superordinate
story.
Write the story that governs all other
stories,
which you might think of as the king of
all stories.
And that's part of the reason why I told
you about the mess of the table and
creation myth
in the Mesopotamian creation at the
Martech
voluntarily confronts time map who's the
agent of chaos and considered thesis and
it makes the world and for the
Mesopotamians that was the rule of the
king who came as long as the king.
He acted out Marta,
then the culture progress properly.
And so the Mesopotamians sad,
except they didn't say it,
they acted it out,
they act it out.
The idea that the most super story
should be
respect for the process that generates
all stories.
Right,
and that's,
wow,
that's sort of a paradox.
I guess we represented that
this way.
Do you have a story when you're a child
and it's basically an authoritarian
story,
which isn't it someone else's is God
usually your parents at least if you're
lucky,
that doesn't work forever because it
soon becomes evident not because your
parents failed,
but because you change that your parents
aren't Gordon,
that there's problems that they can
solve,
which is to say that there are unknown
or anomalous phenomena that emerge that
your parents can attribute the term
meaning to.
And usually what that means is that you
have to adopt the,
what it means is that you come to adopt
the beliefs of the then
initiation rituals,
which usually involve,
well Elliot,
he says all initiation rituals involved
the regression to the beginnings.
In fact,
Iliana was convinced that all archaic
people's,
whenever they attempted to create
something,
a new,
whenever it was,
they always construed the creation of
something new.
In terms of reference to the cosmo going
with myth,
which is
chaos gives birth to the original set of
parents who in turn give birth to a
divine son who in turn separates them
from the archaic people.
Every act of creation replaced the cause
with money.
Yet we know a little bit about why that
is now too because it does seem that
whenever you rearrange any aspects of
your story at any level of analysis,
you do go through a routine like that
says your presumptions are wrong,
which basically means that the meaning
that you attribute to things is not
stable and you have to readjust those
and during that period of readjustment
your emotions are dysregulated and the
mythological way of referring to that in
a sense,
at least in part,
you return to the state preceding the
division of order and chaos.
Every act of creation is
has the mythological structure of the
construction of the world.
Anyways,
the group tells you how to be
and it provides a good answer when
you're an adolescent to the problems
that poses that are posed to you as a
consequence of your development that
you're,
Karen's cannot answer.
The problem is is that a group provides
a determined a dancer,
which is a list of rules.
Essentially it says that good is such
and such and that bad or evil,
it's such in session,
which is perfectly fine under most
conditions,
but it does upon location ochre that the
fact of the group presents a problem or
the group's notion of how to adapt to
the environment is wrong.
That happens,
for example,
when if you have a group belief that's
very strong and I have one that's very
strong,
we engage in a dispute that results in
our mutual the minds and for me that
indicates that there's a problem.
I mean,
it's a strange situation because it
isn't the case that under many
conditions people will risk their own
extinction in order to maintain the
structure of their roots.
So there you can take the position that
you know the best thing to do is to die
for the fatherland,
which basically means that
even the problem as extreme as the fact
that your group identification might
kill you isn't sufficient problem to
indicate that there's something wrong
with its structure.
I have some extreme authoritarian
position,
but we're going to take the position
that the fact that group
in our caused conflict is an indication
that there's something wrong with the
idea that the group is the final
solution to all of your problems.
It's a choice
if you can.
We know that you have to have group
identification in order to make sense of
your emotional experience because you
need a way of limiting the meaning the
things offered to you to some
comprehensive aligned acceptable domain.
What we also know that group
identification has its own set of
problems,
so what we need is a solution that has
all of the advantages of group
identification without any of the
disadvantages.
Positive parents are the positive
alternative three to this chart as the
capacity not to identify with the group
but to move to a state where giving due
respect to the group you identify with
the process that brings it into being,
which makes you the agent that it,
no,
which makes you determine that the
process that constructs the group is
actually more important than the group
itself and that gives you,
that gives you a way to be,
which basically means a structure that
regulates your emotions and also
something that attributes to determine
the meaning to all of them.
All of these experiences
first and adolescence.
That's identification with her.
And then the second one,
the identification,
the group hero.
Okay.
In the first case it's not
identification with the parents,
it's reliance on their word dependence.
Yeah,
I was on the crew.
Yeah.
And that would be identification with
the parents are actually in the second
stage because that's basically,
if you think of the group as sort of an
abstract,
that parent,
which is a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at,
in fact usually what your parents are
when you're a child.
He's not so much of your parents as
those representatives of the group that
you have to come into contact with.
Right.
That's part of the reason I think why
it's often difficult because this comes
up frequently with people who have the
dependent type of neurotic personality,
so they can't disassociate themselves
from their parents because they don't
know that their parents know that what
they see in their parents isn't the
group and not the parents.
This is especially true.
I think that the father,
your father is more than an individual
in a sense.
He's also the intermediary that you
first encountered who embodies all of
culture and as a consequence he's a fit
a finger.
In a sense that's much more powerful
than P is when construed simply as an
individual.
Yes.
Where is the identification and we kind
of stuff.
If the,
the goal of the journey is a dedication
here,
there's a particular,
like you said,
your event and it's on the parents,
which is also a culture.
Where is it?
Right?
It depended on the,
on the cell.
Well,
what do you mean by the cell?
I think in terms of their guys in a
different form of neurotic.
Yeah.
Oh you mean selfishness?
Oh,
I see.
I see what you mean.
We're being being filled by themself
like self dependence,
so,
oh yeah.
That's why I was reading something about
that just before we came down.
There's a newspaper article about when
the free ball moisture's new papers for
my sister
has been making the claim recently.
The aggressive behaviors associated with
inflated self esteem.
Now he puts that,
it's an interesting paper because he
puts that in the following context.
You know,
in elementary schools and junior high
schools across the United States,
the self esteem movement has been making
great inroads and the self esteem
movement basically proposes that as long
as you feel good about yourself,
nothing else matters.
And the problem with that is that it
uses indiscriminate positive
reinforcement,
which I regard actually as a form of
abuse.
So it makes the world unpredictable or
reward you regardless of what you do.
What I'm telling you essentially is that
what you do has zero meaning,
right?
Because it's not informative.
You change your behavior,
nothing happens.
That means you had,
that means you're powerless basically.
Anyways.
Yeah.
I just saw an article in the globe about
that they were saying come studies done
where they had the head,
uh,
ask a group of Japanese students of
American students who had both taken.
Right.
And that's the same article taking math
tests,
how they felt about themselves in the
Japanese and scored a considerable
amount of higher and they feel so good
about themselves or the American kids at
that point I felt great.
Yeah.
Right,
right,
right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Um,
but that's another point that if the
whole point of behaviors to regulate
your emotions and you're able to
regulate your emotion that way,
why bother with,
well,
because they'd only,
no,
that's a good,
that's a perfectly good question.
That that ties into some other social
psychological research on self
deception.
You actually feeling good about yourself
despite the actual environment only
worked with for a very short period of
time.
That's the problem.
It's a good short term solution.
You know,
if you can,
if you fail an exam,
you can say,
well,
that's okay.
I'm still,
all right,
well that's,
that's fine.
Except that failing the exam might
actually mean that you don't get through
graduate school for example,
like sooner or later these,
let's say these,
these,
uh,
these things that you're not going to
pay attention to it,
that you've decided not to pay attention
to,
are going to accumulate and,
and beat you up.
So that's the problem.
We know neurotic solutions work.
That's why people use them,
right.
We know that it's true.
It's like
the problem is they don't work in the
long term.
That's why,
let me read you some,
I still have answer answered your
question.
I just sort of zipped around.
Um,
it's a complicated question and that's
why I'm sort of hitting it from
different perspectives.
And I know you addressed this issue
before.
The thing that you're talking about has
more to do with presuming that you're
right,
despite all evidence to the contrary.
And that's,
that's,
that's worship of the self in the sense
that you mean and I'm not going to talk
about that anymore because the starting
next week,
everything that we discussed for the
rest of the course is directly related
to that.
Look.
We've given this diagram here.
We've talked a little bit about the
structure of chaos,
the chaos that exists prior to the
division of things into order in chaos.
So that's represented by the drag.
Okay.
We've talked about the unknown and it's
caused of aspect and it's negative
aspect.
We've talked about the known in its
beneficial and secure aspect and as
tyranny,
but we've only talked about the
individual in terms of the positive
aspect,
which is the process that separates the
sky and the earth or that distinguishes
between order and chaos.
We've never talked about the negative
aspect of the individual and I think
that's probably why this question keeps
popping up in your mind.
In the census we only have five sixths
of the story and there's a big hole
where the other sixth should be and
that's what we're going to start to talk
about next week.
So part of the part of the question is
like,
why is it,
why is it that?
Why would you ever say,
put yourself in a situation where you
tell yourself a story that you know not
to be true?
It's a very peculiar idea because
animals don't do that.
I mean,
chimpanzees will use a little bit of
deception on other chimpanzees,
but that's about as developed as
deception seems to be in the animal
came.
I don't think there's any evidence
whatsoever that animal's actually ever
fooled themselves,
but we do that all the time now.
That's part of the path it's defined in
mythology is a very dangerous one.
Part of what we want to figure out is
why would people be motivated to do
that?
It's like part of it.
Part of the problem is is that you know,
you're cruising along your track and a
piece of information emerges and you
think that piece of information is so
terrible that I can't deal with it.
So it's just shunted aside and you're in
a box,
which is your story that you know to be
insufficient,
but you're also not sufficiently
convinced of your own adaptive potential
to risk stepping outside of the box.
But then you're in in the little trap
that gets smaller and smaller all the
time.
There's a story in this manuscript about
a north African tribe called the mayor
boats,
and they do this interesting little
ritual to Scorpion.
I don't know if this is a true story or
not.
It might just be a matter that doesn't
matter.
You take a scarf and they put it in the
sand and they draw a big circle around
it.
And the Scorpion,
who's sort of upset about being
surrounded by these larger creatures
attempts to escape.
And as soon as it comes up to the,
the groove in the sand,
it just runs around the circle and we'll
cross the border.
So then the mayor both takes the circle
and divides it in half and the skirt and
zips around inside the half,
sir.
And then the mirror divides the circle
into quarters and the Scorpion is
getting more and more frantic all the
time,
confined to the smaller and smaller
space.
Finally,
they bisect the area so drastically that
the Scorpion can't move and then it
stings itself.
Yeah.
That's a good story of what happens to
you if you constantly believe that
you're in a position,
it's actually better than the one that
you're in.
I do.
I'm telling you that story again because
I do think it's related directly to the
question that you're at,
that you're asking.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
have you started reading paradise lost?
that's a story about what happens when
you think that what you know is all that
needs to be.
No,
that's right.
That's,
that's the adoption of the position of
false on students and the consequences
of that are that you ended up in a
situation that's very much analogous to
that of the skirting.
So
I don't know whether to,
I don't really know whether to close who
was in this discussion and start the new
section when you finish it.
Cause we haven't talked about these
different forms of the normalist
information yet.
Well we should just go to the next
section.
Let's take a look into
this.
I guess what we'll do,
I'll be
okay.
One of the things that we discussed just
before the class broke was how and why
is it the stories came to be
constructive and it's part of the reason
that we were interested in you because
it's obvious that some of the stories
that you tell yourself,
you don't actually know.
For example,
if you would have read Mark Mesopotamian
creation myth three years ago,
my guess is that
it would obstruct you as bizarre tale of
not as something that had any meaning
that was relevant to the present time.
It's not that easy to figure out what it
might mean for sort of go on to be
elected as the highest of all the gods
and then go out and kind of have to drag
it from the purely a literal
perspective.
That doesn't seem to be a story that has
very much meaning.
Um,
but it's a very old story.
And if you track its development
historically,
you can see how the idea is that we're
embedded in that story
conditioned all sorts of behaviors that
we actually engaging in as far as this
is of course open to to any about
historical interpretation.
But it seems to me that you can make a
reasonable case that the Mesopotamian,
the idea that there's something divine
about the capacity of conquer the
unknown and to construct things as a
consequence developed into the Egyptian
idea that the optimal pharaoh with
someone who's similar,
Paisley embodied the state and updated
the state.
And it's not much of a leap from that to
the Judeo Christian perspective,
which says that there's something
eternal,
immortal,
and divine about each person.
Now,
if you accept that line of logic,
then you have to also accept the idea
that you can act out stories by yourself
and with others in huge groups without
understanding what the stories mean.
And the next step of logic after that is
that if you don't understand what the
stories mean,
what form did they make?
How is it that they're coded?
But how is it that they exist?
They're not part of the objective world
so to speak.
They're not something that you can talk
about unless you tell stories.
They're not something you know.
At least you don't know them well enough
to say what they mean,
but nonetheless they conditioned all of
your behaviors.
So the question then is what form did
that take?
That's what this diagram was adapting.
Illustrate
every level of analysis.
The story you tell yourself is informed
by a variety of sources of information
ranging from the purely behavioral to
the entirely abstract,
which is to say how your question is how
is it that I should have and the answer
is well you should act and here's a list
of rules that are explicit or you should
act like person a acts,
which means that you should imitate
them,
which is what you'll do naturally
anyways or all act out some hypothetical
sequences and you can,
you can coffee them and that would be
the whole drama.
Or I can tell you a story and you can
absorb whatever information you can from
that.
Use that to govern your behavior instead
of the stories you tell yourself are
constructed as a consequence of your
encounter with information at all sorts
of different levels of analysis and
different stories are coded at different
levels of analysis.
And it strikes me that the farther out
you go,
as I said before,
the farther out you know,
which is the more superordinate the
story is the less
explicit the story becomes,
which is to say it's more coated in
procedural knowledge and also the older
it gets,
which is I do think it's reasonable to
think that as you move up the hierarchy
he moved back in time.
That's a good way of looking at it so
that the stories that you act out at the
most superordinate level of analysis are
unconscious.
And what does that mean?
It means that everyone just act them out
and could hardly even describe them or
we have some stories about them and
that's the best we've been able to do.
And no one actually says,
well this is what that story means.
We just act as if the story's true and
we act as if it's true because,
well that's a,
that's a tough question at least because
it works.
And the funny thing is is that the same
story keeps emerging in culture after
culture.
So it kind of leads you to the
conclusion that there is actually one
story that works only who knows if
that's true.
So anyways,
we,
we tried to tie that,
this idea to the idea that there are
different memory systems.
Does that make sense?
I mean did the under d the understand
how it is that you can figure out how to
behave without being able to come up
with a description of how it is that you
behave?
Is that,
that seems reasonably clear to everyone.
I mean,
we are conditioning each other's
behavior all the time.
That's the basic idea.
It's right.
Whenever we're engaged in any sort of
interaction,
we're modifying our own behavior and the
behavior of others.
And we do that to everyone we encounter
and everyone does it.
Everyone does it over a huge expanse of
time.
And as a consequence,
a pattern emerges that we more or less
all,
etc. And when we don't accept that
there's a big fight and someone wins and
someone loses and whoever wins their
behavior continues in the future.
So we gathered patterns of behavior over
time and integrate them into a statement
that's more or less coherent.
And what we're trying to do is to figure
out what's the essence of that coherent
and long lasting statement.
I agree with what you're saying that um,
people can't come up with a conscious
representation of how they act,
you know,
or a lot of things.
But I think they do know,
um,
of ways of acquiring,
even if they can't consciously say,
well,
somebody else is doing and then they
want to give it those behaviors
themselves.
They know that they should imitate other
people.
Absolutely.
And I,
that seems to me that's a very peculiar
thing and it's the thing that I think
provides the strongest evidence for the
existence of something like humans
archetype.
Because one of the things you could say
is,
well,
why do you admire someone?
Well you might say it's because they can
get something that you want.
Well that's a pretty mechanistic
explanation and you don't really have to
pause at any underlying predisposition.
It's just that you have to want
something and you have to be able to
observe that someone else gets it.
And maybe that's sufficient.
But it strikes me that the capacity do
admire someone is more deeply rooted
than that.
And it's not purely driven by
observations that someone else gets what
you want more effectively.
And it seems to me that that's actually
one of the things that bootstrap to
children's development can.
I can remember when I was very young,
well not all that,
you know,
you'll get some great one.
How much I admired the boy across the
street who was in grade three and for me
that was a huge gap at that time.
And he was someone I want it to be like.
And I don't really think it was perhaps
it was at least in part because he could
do things I couldn't,
but it seemed to be something that was
more global than that.
It wasn't,
it wasn't built up.
I think from repeated observations that
uh,
you know,
he could ride a bike faster than me or,
but you know,
maybe that's maybe,
maybe that was,
do you think it's just that same sort of
idea but didn't buy it in a more general
way?
Like he knows what to do.
I mean there's just,
yeah,
I'm comfortable in doing that.
Well true enough,
true enough.
But like
that you sense that his story is better
than you are.
Okay,
fine.
Fair enough.
But it is also the case that children
start to imitate at such an early age
that it's hard to believe that the
reason they're doing it is because they
drawn an inference.
You know what I mean?
Because like kids,
kids,
there is some evidence that newborns can
imitate.
You may want to take facial gestures.
It's debatable,
but it doesn't take very long after that
to find,
it isn't much after birth that children
do imitate.
And you can say that's because they are
driven by these sorts of mechanistic
inferences.
But it looks to me like it's something
more,
more profound.
I want to just tell you one other piece
of evidence that's something equivalent
to this.
People will have to Rett Syndrome,
types of disinhibition,
disinhibition of procedural memory
habits is what it looks like.
Uh,
if you feed them little bits of
antipsychotic medication alone,
often damp and out there motor ticks,
but they're called techs and the people
take them a ticket,
something like that.
You know that ticks can be very complex.
Like people who are,
have tourette's syndrome can do very
complex things.
I saw a film once of a sculptor who had
two rats and he was a realistic
sculpture and he was very,
very good at it.
He had two nets unbelievably badly and
his motor behaviors completely
dysregulated and basically he'd sit down
and kind of motor tic would get them and
so he'd get up and walk over and then he
could sort of control it.
So we adjust the stereo and that was it.
Like it was all involuntary behavior
until they go up near the Stereo and
then you can control it enough to to
just add his twist to the behavior and
then he'd come back and sit down and he
was like bouncing up and down like this
all the time and that's how we do with
sculpture.
Like you'd be sitting and he'd have a
tick and he'd get up and he move and
then has gone from being over there.
He pick up his knife and make it
two rats.
The reason I'm telling you this story is
because people with Tourette's syndrome
are very,
very,
very imitative.
Like there's a story actually where I
used to live in northern Alberta a
little bit farther north.
There's a group of how to rights.
I think they were a hunter rights.
They might've been mennonites.
Anyways,
the problem with these isolated
religious populations as they tend to
get someone in bread,
and one of the consequences of this in
this northern colony was very high rates
of Tourette Syndrome.
One of the,
one of the stories I remember about that
was all of these,
I think you were mennonites sitting in a
church together.
A bird flew into the church and they all
flat,
large proportion of population
involuntary flap their hands because
they were imitating the bird and two
rights.
One of the things the two reds also does
to people is give them an uncanny
ability to mimic and caricatures or
other people by copying their motor
habits.
Yeah.
Anyways,
the reason I'm telling you this is
because it looks like the capacity to
mimic is something that's underneath the
capacity to form abstract
representations.
It's more,
it's more primordial.
Oh,
so this is,
this is just to say that it's
biological.
It's hard wiring.
That's right.
That's what I'm saying now.
That's why I was talking about the why.
I think there's some support for the
union notion of an architect with
regards to the mutation is you can come
up with a good explanation for why
people imitated by saying,
I see that what you do is more efficient
than what I do,
and I think that does drive invitation
to some degree,
but there's also another level of
invitation and it's,
it's more
how do you,
how do you select what?
What's the,
what's the selection process?
Why the boy that you focused on?
Well,
that's a good,
that's a good question.
I mean,
yeah,
I guess I don't know what level of
analysis you're asking that question.
Do you mean in general,
why do people do it?
You're the way you're describing
mutation without the inferential part.
I mean,
it's not as a result then what's the
process?
That's a good,
now that's it.
That's a very good question.
I guess I would,
hm.
I don't know the answer to that.
I guess I would.
I would surmise,
did I ever show you that picture,
that eastern picture of the recurrent
artists sat?
Fuck you remember that?
Yeah.
The image of basically the image of the
savior that's constantly recurring
throughout time.
I think that,
I think that the notion that we have an
innate sense of what's appropriate
globally is true.
So I would say that,
but it's,
it's,
it's like with gray leg geese I guess is
a great like goose will attach itself to
something.
So it has the capacity to develop an
exceptional attachment,
but it also has to see something in its
environment for that capacity to
manifest itself.
Right?
That same printing,
and I suspect that's what our general
proclivity is like.
It's like say it's analogous to the
notion of the possibility for developing
condition fears more easily to some
phenomenal than others.
So like if I want to make you afraid of
something,
say I take you into the lab and I show
you some pictures of an electric outlet
and I give you an electric shock.
Every time you see one or I show you a
picture of a snake and I give you an
electric shock,
every time you see it,
you'll develop conditioned fear to the
picture of the snake faster than to the
picture of the electric outlet.
So it's not exactly as if you're
innately afraid of the snake is just
that in the presence of a snake you're,
it's easier for you to develop fear and
my guess is,
but we kind of have the same or similar
sort of mechanism operating with regards
to heroic behavior.
It's it's,
we have the capacity this to no one when
we see it and it's at the level of a
global pattern recognition.
So that's a speculation
isn't everything that we know how to do.
Irritation or their child learns how to
speak by imitating.
Well that's a good,
that's another good example of the same
sort of things the child does not
exactly learn to speak by imitating.
Child has to have the capacity to speak.
It's like if you take a chimpanzee,
no matter what you do,
the chimpanzee,
it's not going to learn to be a concert
pianist.
It's because the chimpanzee doesn't have
the capacity to imitate that sort of
behavior.
It's also the case that no matter what
you do with chimpanzee,
let's start going to learn to talk
because the chimpanzee doesn't have the
capacity to imitate speech.
Now,
some people say that's because of the
structure of this,
the morphology of its speech unit,
but they're not very good at
manipulating symbols either.
You know,
they can get a little ways,
but not very far.
A child will pick up language very,
very rapidly.
What's that never hears?
Well then no,
and there also seems to be a certain
critical period,
like if a child isn't exposed to
language within a certain span of time,
say at least by the age of 13 and
there's not gonna be any language
development.
It's not,
and it's not just imitation.
You see,
because the grammatical children make
standard types of grammatical errors
that they didn't hear their parents
make.
So it isn't straight invitation.
That's what skinner thought.
Part of the way it's not true because
children don't hear what Bait,
the grammatical errors that children
make.
Parents don't make.
So they
know.
They act as if they learned moles.
Yeah.
Right.
But that's different,
right?
It's different.
Yeah.
That language is,
the language is not invitation.
Like I have a problem with them is very
much a and hardwired right.
Capacity Children's say words or coach,
they have syntax ability that they've
never heard from them.
Right.
They can put him down and work together
and create sentences that spontaneously
they know that they've never heard
before in your life.
Therefore I don't think it's really
comparable,
you know,
just that.
Um,
I think that both language and the myths
that we understand that we about layout
or don't understand fully tap into the
unconscious because you know,
like these men,
we understand them have symbols just
like the snake now and that tax more
into our unconscious.
Then you know,
the electric,
I think it's reasonable.
Noam Chomsky,
whose name you're undoubtedly familiar
with is very famous nyt.
He's positive,
the existence of a language acquisition
device,
which is not really all that informative
at the top concept because it doesn't
really say what it is,
but he says,
well,
you need the capacity to develop
language as well as exposure to the
appropriate environmental stimuli
nights.
I would,
I really do thing.
But something similar operates at the
mythological level.
It's like we're hardwired to appreciate
the structure of a narrative we now
otherwise you don't see,
I mean,
how else do you explain the capacity of
children to be interested in stories?
It's not like you teach them that it's
the,
if they weren't bloody well interested
in stories,
you couldn't teach them anything.
It's like that's the precondition what
you can grab that and then use it to
final information into them.
But you don't teach that it's their
first.
And I think that's,
um,
well I think that's a form of grammar
and really what we're looking at in,
in large part because the grammar of
mythologies.
So like your recognition of your Roy boy
was like a pattern.
I mean,
it's not like a process of inference
from just discrete behaviors right.
Boy does this and I know.
Yeah,
right.
I mean that may contribute to it,
but it's around it's recognition of a
pattern of behavior.
That's right.
He matches.
That's exactly right cause he matches a
pattern that's late in the ideas or
could it be a pattern you learn as a
child with your parents?
Well it could be.
I mean,
yeah you can't.
You can make a plausible case for the
mechanistic,
for the mechanistic acquisition of some
of this sort of thing except for the
fact that imitative behavior seems in
some ways pre abstract and also that
I don't think children learn to be
interested in stories.
I really don't.
I think they have that first.
Do you have anything useful comes to us
in the form of a story or a pattern of
some sorts and it makes sense
evolutionarily that there's going to be
huge selective pressure to be interested
in patterns and stories.
Well,
if that's how they,
that's how you learned to behave.
I mean,
yes,
it isn't the case that,
well,
here's an example.
This is a good example.
I went into Montreal last week and talk,
I'm working on an experimental project.
They're dealing with children who fight
in school.
So we have a population of kids that
were tracked from kindergarten right
till they graduated basically.
And in six of the first 10 years of
their schooling they were rated by
teachers for fighting.
So we can identify kids who are stable
fighters over the long term travel.
It's interesting about these kids,
you know,
you hear the standard routine about
antisocial personalities.
They don't feel any anxiety,
for example.
But these kids are extraordinarily
anxious and I just had an honors student
write me a thesis about men who abused
their wives enough to be brought to the
attention of courts and convicted.
Um,
they tend to be criminal as you'd
suspect,
have lower Iqs,
but they're very,
very,
very anxious and depressed,
which again doesn't fit very well with
the classic picture that he,
social personality,
it looks more like an antisocial
personality,
feels anxious,
but can't use that anxiety to regulate
their behavior.
Those two phenomena being separable,
just to say you could be very,
very anxious,
but unless you know what to do with the
information,
that's not very useful and there's a lot
of reasons for believing.
That's true.
Um,
anyways,
I still want to stay focused on your
question.
Okay.
So you have these kids.
I've tried to figure out what are these
kids like?
Well,
they're aggressive because they fight
and teachers rate them is fighting.
That's the one thing we really know
about them,
but they're very anxious and they're
very depressed.
I think the gentleman I'm working with
there has been studying antisocial
behavior in children for a long time.
Uh,
he's,
I've told you before,
the children's aggressive behavior peaks
at two and then goes down hill.
From there.
You're more aggressive at two,
then you are at any other time in your
life.
It gets socialized somewhere around
between two and three.
You learn these behavioral patterns.
What happens if you don't learn?
That's the question.
That's what's relevant to your topic.
Well,
trump Nye said he's the character who
rented this study said,
you know,
when you're an adult and you don't fit
into your peer group,
like you really don't fit in,
you get put in prison said these kids in
kindergarten,
they're already in prison.
There's just no walls around them.
But just to say that because they
haven't learned the proper behavioral
rituals,
they're ostracized by their peer groups
so they don't fit into the standard
hierarchy outside that hierarchy.
They build their own hierarchy and it's
based on force,
the toughest kid.
So all the kids who get thrown out
cluster and the toughest kid wins.
And that's the genesis.
I'm going only the anti social
personality,
but that whole anti social lifestyle,
it's the same in prisons.
The dominant tire can prison is the
meanest son of a bitch rules.
Well,
that's because outside of the proper
dominance hierarchy,
the property development,
it's hard to be normal socialized
behavior.
That's the default strategy for the
erection of dominance.
Higher at the most mackerel,
uh,
moral system.
That's what needs are as well.
It's the most,
it's the most natural.
If you're,
if you're very impaired,
that's the sort of freeze the motion.
That's right.
It's,
it's the most primitive then,
I mean,
in a sense it's,
well,
it's what you'll come to if you're not
given anything else.
Right,
right.
That's right.
It's what you'll come to if you're not
given anything else.
That's a good way of putting it.
So when you say,
well,
it's very important to pick up on the
appropriate sorts of behaviors as well.
Just an a story about why it's so
important.
And if you don't learn to be properly
prosocial,
like these kids,
they don't,
if someone else has heard,
they won't go over to comfort them.
They don't know how to,
even if you're highly aggressive and you
find a load and you're quite anxious and
depressed,
if you're helpful and you know how to
share,
that's enough to get you into the group.
It's,
it's,
if you're lacking even the most
rudimentary forms of,
of nonaggressive social behavior,
then you were an outcast.
And that's the consequence of not
picking up these initial for whatever
reason.
So yeah,
the consequences are very severe.
So these kids,
by the way,
I think they're the ones that are
indiscriminate,
reinforced because that's how you ruined
a child.
It's like you make sure that the rewards
and punishments they received are
completely uncorrelated with their
behavior because that makes them
powerless completely and makes the world
very frustrating place.
I remember I had a friend in
adolescence,
he drove a white truck and that truck
was dented on.
Every quarter panel was a pickup truck
including insight quarter panels where
various parts of people's bodies had
come into contact with,
with the dash or the roof or whatever
before he was 16 he racked four or five
vehicles.
The most dramatic example of which was
one day I went and a job and on the main
street of our small town in the middle
of winter,
I looked up the street about three
blocks in.
There was a small convenience store
there with a truck parked halfway inside
of it covered with the tarp and it was a
white truck and I thought that's very
likely my friend.
Anyways,
he was indiscriminately reinforced
because every time he wrecked the truck,
he just gotten underway.
You know what ever said stop.
Anyways.
Okay,
so back now,
were there other,
are there other questions?
Okay,
let's have a question.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it's the difference between someone
like,
I don't know much about would happen,
maybe Jesus
or something.
Cool.
Could you say that a lot of the
behaviors that they learned came from
their parents and then they added to
that in their,
in their lifetime.
So is the difference between that and a
and a and a child who doesn't,
who's antisocial,
whatever it is that they are there,
they are not given the opportunity to
learn,
um,
those adaptive behaviors or social
behaviors,
whatever the cause of the peer group
ostracized.
Yeah.
Well,
I guess,
I guess if you,
if you thought about it in this terms,
well those kids are even followed up at
this point.
It's hard to say.
It's hard to say because they don't ever
have anyone reliably that they can
depend on.
Even in Charlotte.
So like this
success here is a precondition for
success here.
It's right.
These kids are identifiable at
kindergarten.
It's like they didn't even get to the
point where they're acceptable to a peer
group,
so the question is what happens to you
if you don't even make it here?
I guess what happens is that you're
thrown out into chaos where you organize
yourself according to the principal we
just discussed,
which is what can you do when you can't
do anything else?
The answer being hurt,
right?
It doesn't really,
and that that,
of course it's pretty much just
dependent on your on how mean you are
and your size I guess.
Okay.
I'm going to read you something from
tolstoy in this will help us discuss the
different sorts of different manners in
which and the homeless inflammation can
present itself.
This is in toasters convention
confessions.
I remember that when I was 11 years old
at high school boy named Devola Dinka
now long since dead,
visited us one Sunday with an
announcement of the latest discovery
made at school.
If discovery was that there is no god
and the things they were teaching us,
we're nothing but fairy tales.
This was in 1838 I remember how this
news captured the interest of my older
brothers even let me in on their
discussions.
I remember that we were all very excited
that we took this news to be both
engaging in entirely possible,
okay
tolstoy's confession or basically a
description of the consequences of
having been exposed to that piece of
information on his entire life and it is
the case or it was the case for him that
at least by his own interpretation,
the dramatic consequences of that
discovery didn't manifest themselves
fully in his consciousness until he was
middle aged and well,
well established.
As a successful author say,
well,
he hit a piece of,
he hit a piece of anomalous information
while he was pursuing some relatively
trivial task and was unable to determine
the proper magnitude of that anomalous
information for perhaps 40 years.
It kept moving up the hierarchy of
stories destroying them as it went
because his,
as Nietzsche pointed out,
Judeo Christian morality which
characterized the behavior of the
Russians in 1838 is predicated on the
idea that there is a god.
If that's the most fundamental
presupposition,
and if you blow that presupposition,
then you blow the morality.
Now,
you may not know that it's gone,
but the fact just the fact that you
don't know that it's gone doesn't
necessarily mean that it will.
It'll disappear whether you know it's
gone or not.
Neat.
You said at one point that if you kill
the roots of a tree,
eventually the branches will die.
You might take a long period of time.
Anyways,
tolstoy said since ancient times when
the life of which I do know something
began people who knew the arguments
concerning the vanity of life,
the arguments that reveal to me its
meaninglessness live nonetheless
bringing to life a meaning of their own.
Since the time when people somehow began
to live,
this meaning of life is being with them
and they have led this life up to my own
time.
Everything that is in me and around me
is the fruit of their knowledge of life.
The very tools of thought by which I
judge life and condemn it were created
not by me,
but by them.
I was born educated and have grown up
thanks to them.
They dug the iron,
taught us how to cut the timber,
tamed the cattle and the horses showed
us how to sow crops and live together.
They brought order to our lives as the
mythological ancestors.
They taught me how to think and how to
speak.
I had their offspring nurse by them
reared by the talk,
by them I think according to their
thoughts,
their words and their,
I have proved to them that it is all
meaningless.
I mean have them with me as it happens
with everyone who contracts that fatal
internal disease.
At first there were the insignificant
symptoms of an ailment which the patient
ignores.
Then these symptoms recur more and more
frequently until they merge into one
continuous duration of suffering.
The suffering increases and before he
can turn around the patient discovers
what he already knew.
The thing he had taken for a mere in
disposition is in fact the most
important thing on earth to him is in
fact,
and that's the story of the information
moving up.
Thy are historics I think.
I guess this is conference there.
You could draw an analogy to,
to discovering that you have a fatal
illness.
I mean,
let's say you wake up one morning and he
says,
and he makes them,
he uses the metaphor,
you have a stitch in your side,
anything.
Well that's going to make it much more
difficult to get to work.
So you construe the anomalous event with
regards to to a particular story.
You say,
well,
this,
this thing which I am now in calibrating
has the status of a minor inconvenience,
right?
When you say it's only going to
interfere with a story that's nested way
down,
but it doesn't go away and perhaps it
gets worse and you start to wonder,
well,
perhaps it's more serious than I
thought,
which means there's more to this bit of
enormous information that first met the
eye.
It sort enough the next day so that you
have to stay in bed.
So then you start thinking,
well,
what's the proper level of analysis to
consider this anomalous information with
respect to,
and you don't know,
well they need to go to the doctor and
the doctor says,
well you need some more tests.
While this information is starting to
think of it,
this is the best way to think of it.
It's only metaphor that it's only
metaphor.
Wherever something anomalous occurs,
there's a hole in the way that you look
at the world.
And that whole can widen or narrow
depending on your interpretation and
what you see through the whole is the
unknown.
And your job in a sense is to keep all
the holes covered.
Now here's something the unknown is
peaking its head through and you don't
know how big the thing that's keeping
his head through is it's just the tail
of a dragon or just the nose of a drag
as about whether you're trying to do is
to figure it out.
So I guess interject came out maybe
because the way and find out what
someone's dominance hierarchy is.
Go ahead.
How do you mean?
Well,
use the example of a good example of an
athlete.
Um,
let's say that you get the stitch and
you get some stitching your side at
first you think to yourself,
well,
you know this,
this make it difficult for me to get
through my day and you keep going and
um,
it gets worse and worse and you see what
level of analysis they take it to next,
do they next day,
well I need to,
this will because this will interfere
with my schoolwork.
Do I need to,
um,
my off my sports?
Or is it the other way around that,
that me with the status of the various
nested goals and stuff,
right?
Are you going to see that by forcing
someone into the novel or,
I see what you're saying.
So if I put a limitation on your
behavior or if one emerges,
you're going to determine what's worth
tossing and that'll give you what's
worth throwing away.
Basically.
If you can only do 90% of the things
that you're doing right now,
what falls into the category of the 10%
that can be eliminated?
Sort of,
I think more along the lines of what are
the order in which you would consider.
Yes,
yes.
Fair enough.
So yeah.
Well that's,
yeah.
Well I think that's perhaps part of the
reason why,
uh,
you know,
people who have recovered from a very
serious illness or sometimes people who
aren't even going to be covers say,
well,
at least this has taught me what was
important.
So that's,
that's a perfectly reasonable
observation.
So anyways,
you go to the doctor and what your
attempt is,
when you ask the doctor what is going
on,
what you're basically saying is like,
what subsection of my nested stories is
this event going to destroy?
Right.
That's what you want to determine.
I read this is quite interesting.
You see and that's a terrible situation
to be.
And so you're at the doctor and you were
faced with something that's unknown so
that then you're very anxious,
high red,
all the educational attempts so far to
convince homosexual men to use condoms
have resulted in failure globally.
Um,
when AIDS first manifested itself,
there was a decrease in the kind of
behavior that spreads aged and an
increase in use of condoms for,
for a substantial period of time.
But you know,
the days is sort of running the mail,
so to speak.
The behaviors have basically returned to
baseline level.
And there is some studies that
demonstrate that men who engage in
extremely high risk sexual behavior are
more anxious and depressed before they
are diagnosed with aids.
And then after.
And the reason for that I think is that
any possibility has been,
that's right.
That's right.
Any defined actuality is better than the
know.
And that's,
that's a good story for illustrating how
that's the case.
Like it's better to know than not to
know.
No matter what it is that you know
there's definitely the breath is worst
than yes.
That's what it means.
That's why.
That's why in psychotherapy people will
always will continue to do things that
they know will hurt them rather than
risk change cause threat.
That's right.
That's what people do like hope it's
better than reward and punishment is
better than threat.
Right,
so our primary reinforcers are less
salient then our secondary reinforcers.
It is peculiar.
It is peculiar,
but I think that is the case because it
is drugs that for a while it is drugs
that activate are the systems that
mediate hope that we find most
enthralling and it is the key.
I do believe that like the devil you
know is the better one.
You don't that it's the oldest though
that that's one of the reasons why this
sort of theoretical approach is so
useful is because it gives you insight
into why people won't change,
but why won't they change?
Well,
in order to change,
you have to stop believing in it.
Stopped doing what you're doing.
Well,
what does that mean?
it means for an intermediary period of
time,
all things are novel and all normal
things produce anxiety.
And if you're terrified of anxiety and
you don't believe that you can cope with
it,
you can't do it.
So what are the jobs you have as a
psychotherapist is not to minimize the
anxiety that you're a patient feels,
but to endeavor to demonstrate to them
that they can tolerate more of it than
they think.
Yeah,
that's catalog.
That's your attempt to capitalize
identification with the hero.
It's just the fact of anxiety isn't so
bad.
It's the fact that you think that you
can deal with it.
That's what's so bad.
Cause you're never going to convince
anybody that the world is not a
threatening place.
So
okay.
Anyway.
So one of the things that you're doing
when you engage in exploratory behavior
is trying to figure out at what level of
analysis that particular normals piece
of information actually where it's
actually most appropriately conceived
them,
which is to say what does it mean that
you're trying to fit it into a
framework?
While it store basically says that his,
this piece of information that he
accidentally encountered at school,
which is pretty much inevitable.
No,
the Russians in 1838 we're still pretty
backwards society compared to the rest
of Europe in Europe had gone through.
It's,
it's great contact with the idea that
God was dead as early as,
as the,
as the times when Galileo came into
conflict with,
with the Catholic church,
I mean this would be going on in Europe
for a long time,
for 400 years before the news washed in
from western Europe over Russia.
Russia was a feudal society that was
tottering on very on,
on shaky legs,
just read,
just waiting in a sense for something to
push it over.
The news from western Europe pushed it
over.
It took to a story 30 years to figure
out or for the information to have its
full impact on total store and I would
say that I think it's reasonable to say
that what that information did to
Tolstoy,
he did to the whole culture 50 years
later.
That's why I want you to read those Dsq
is the devils,
because Dostoevsky's writing about a
Russia that had held on to feudalism 200
300 years longer than it actually should
have the last year,
a peon country to undergo a modern
revolution.
When we know the consequences of the
revolution,
it's Orthodox.
Christianity was pushed over,
left a huge void in the Russian psyche
that was filled by Marxism.
Anyways,
tolstoy was a genius and one of the
consequences of being a genius is that
those things that eventually happened to
everyone have to you first.
So
that's,
that's an interesting thing.
You know,
it seems to me that
we did,
we do.
This is,
this is a strange,
strange thing to think.
I guess we tend to think that the future
happens everywhere at the same time.
It's like we all come into contact with
the future at the same time,
but that's not really true.
You know,
the people that we think of as geniuses,
our people in whom the future happens
first and then usually isolates them.
That's why they look like profits.
I said,
I think in a sense it's almost as if the
future pours through them first,
then out into the culture.
Yeah.
I mean it depends on what,
it depends on what you think of
thinking.
If you think I'm thinking of something
you do,
then that whole line of argument is
nonsensical.
But if you think of thoughts as
something you encounter,
okay,
then it starts to make it a little bit
more sense.
Anyways,
the thing that had taken for a myriad
disposition is in fact the most
important is in fact,
this is exactly what happened to me.
I realized that this was northern,
it's definitely element,
but something very serious ended.
If the same question should continue to
recur,
I would have to answer them and I tried
to answer the questions seem to be such
foolish,
simple,
childish westerns.
But as soon as I laid my hands on and
try and resolve them,
I was immediately convinced,
first of all,
but they were not childish and foolish,
but the most vital and profound
questions in life.
And so I couldn't believe that no matter
how much I bought them,
there was no way I could resolve.
So tolstoy had not only thought here he
was the paradigmatic example of having
gone there.
Right?
He was as successful as you could
possibly be within the confines of a
group and even perhaps have made some
movements towards the next stage of
development,
given that he was undoubtedly a very
creative individual.
So he says it,
he says himself,
I should have been considered a
completely happy man.
This was when I was not yet 50 years
old.
I had a good loving and beloved wife
find children and largest state that was
growing and expanding without any effort
on my card or the never before.
I was respected by friends and
acquaintances,
praised by strangers and could claim a
certain renown without really diluting
myself were over.
I was not physically and mentally
unhealthy on the contrary,
and I enjoyed the physical and mental
vigor such as I have rarely encountered
among others my age
physically I could keep up with the
peasants working in the fields.
Mentally I could work eight and 10 hours
at a stretch that's suffering any after
effects from the strain.
And in such a state of affairs,
I came to a point where I could not
live.
And even though I fear death,
I had to employ ruses against myself to
keep from committing suicide.
Perfect example of an entirely well
adaptive matt,
he encountered with a piece of anomalous
information that blew his ability to
believe in all of the determinant
meanings that his group identification
have provided for him.
And as a consequence,
he descended in voluntarily into chaos
and just about died as a consequence.
He said,
and details this to some degree in his
confessions made tolstoy literally was
suicidal for a long period of time.
So
it was three,
one of the tragic consequences of
abstraction.
I mean,
this is,
it's coming from the top down there and
there's no right.
You should be unhappy from a practical
point of view.
Right.
Well that's,
that's one of the things that I wanted
to sort of deal with today is,
I mean,
this story,
is this,
right?
I mean,
what toss do I encountered was a
stranger idea.
I'm the problem with an idea.
This is why the pen is mightier than the
sword.
The problem with an idea
is that once it's up here,
you can just say it like you can make
your point in,
in a paragraph or two.
Say if the point is uh,
it's absurd to believe in religious
presuppositions and you buttress that
with page of or to have documentation of
the reasons why it's absolutely obvious
that it's absurd.
Then you're,
you're providing information who's ease
of communication belies its danger and
also obscures how difficult it was for
the information to have being generated.
That's the thing about abstraction is
that for me to make a statement like
that
mapped over a long span of time that any
number of people may have had to die in
order to make that information in order
to generate that information.
And I think that's part of the reason
why we're so constantly interested in
the story of Galileo.
He was someone who produced a piece of
anomalous information and was branded
the heretic by the Catholic Church.
And he was like,
here's a person who opened the doorway
for the,
for the scientific overthrew religious
ideas.
But the fact that we can commonly
discuss issues like that now is a
consequence of the fact that centuries
of battles about ideas like this,
if taking me,
have taken place in the past,
sometimes purely intellectually,
sometimes as the consequence of actual
wars all compacted up into a few
abstracted phrases that can easily be
delivered,
also delivered across cultures.
And that's
so will you can see the actions of
strangers can become abstracted up into
words and then transmitted well,
that's the thing that's so funny is that
once it's abstract,
you can be a very ineffectual
personality and nonetheless have the
capability to have a huge impact on
things because you can serve as the
carrier of information that you could
not possibly have generated yourself.
And that's part of the reason why our
technological power makes us so
increasingly dangerous.
I think because we have access to all
the power that people have developed in
the past,
regardless of whether or not we have the
kind of personalities that are capable
of using that power wisely.
So there's politics in a nutshell,
right?
Not just politics though.
It's the case with every field of
endeavor.
It doesn't matter where you look,
it's the case.
And as,
as we develop our technological power
more and more,
that's increasingly the case.
That's why someone like,
I don't remember his name,
a character in the,
in Southeast Asia who brought down
Barings Bank.
That's a good example of the power of
abstraction.
That's right.
He's playing with nothing and devastated
the whole community because he's just
playing with abstractions and they were
just numbers.
They're bits even.
But because things hadn't been
abstracted upsell so tremendously,
his casual movements had huge impact.
What makes it an homeless idea of
threatened and not just a ridiculous,
I mean why go go?
It was so positions would threatened.
Why were they perceived of as,
I mean not as substitute.
That'll be the speculations are just
theory.
It was considered.
That's good.
That's a really good question.
I suspect.
Look,
that's a really good question because it
also ties in with other peculiarities.
Like you pointed out for example that
well and everyone knows this to be the
case.
You know sometimes you're a prophet
crying in the wilderness,
which basically means that you have a
message that no one listened to and the
reason for that is,
well it might be because you're,
you know,
you're,
you're fundamentally deranged and what
you have to say has no relevance,
but it also may be that you're so far
ahead of your time so to speak,
that no one that you talked to can
understand what you're saying,
which is very much related to the
question that you're asking.
I guess I would say that there must be
an op then this,
this,
this ties into the last chapter that
we'll discuss,
which has to do the ability to use your
interest as a motive regulating your
progress.
The gods ski said there's a zone of
proximal development.
This is a complicated thing to try and
understand and I really haven't gotten
it completely straightened out.
All of this diagram helps a bit.
You're saying if you're faced with an
anomalous piece of information,
what makes it meaningful instead of
incomprehensible?
And it must be that there must be,
like if the idea is here,
maybe it's pretty easy to move it to
here,
but maybe it's pretty difficult to move
it to here if it's here.
So I would say like the reason that the
reason that the Russians,
tolstoy for example,
was so overwhelmed by the idea from
Europe is because at other levels of
analysis,
they already knew the idea.
So it was like dropping us a seed
crystal into a supersaturated solution.
It was the ground was already prepared.
And I also think that's why people
sometimes experience things as
revelations is they already know.
You already know.
Sorry,
I tell you a piece of information.
This is very much relevant to
mythological teaching because again,
what we're discussing in this class,
everyone knows at least up to about here
already.
So when you say move it to here,
well I can always make reference to what
you already know here
also.
That's
so I,
I sit with my children and I watched
bugs bunny cartoons or any movie for
that matter.
They're the oldest one is four and I see
by watching my daughter how much of
what's portrayed in the movie is opaque
information and that's because she
doesn't understand any of the
references.
Like yesterday we were watching Casper,
she doesn't know.
What it goes to is now you can really
explain to anyone when it goes to is,
you know,
because while you think about it,
that's complicated.
I mean it's really complicated.
You have to,
there are a lot of presuppositions
involved in understanding what it goes.
Yes.
For her that's just opaque information.
It's cause she doesn't share like the
movie,
all the movie presumes a certain shared
frame of reference.
Right.
A shared background knowledge
and that's that.
That's
is it.
Is it related to the way of knowing and
not just the idea?
I mean
the church had a way of knowing God all
day or in a different way of knowing.
Right.
It wasn't just the idea that was new.
It was a way of knowing.
Yes.
But that was certainly true in his case.
That's right.
Well that's because the,
the church I think was most concerned,
although it didn't know that explicit
and being with the knowing as knowing
how to behave.
Whereas Galileo was on the track of
knowing as knowing facts and well we
know what the consequences of that of
being,
we haven't been able to distinguish them
very well.
But you know,
if you,
I noticed wandering through various art
museums in Europe,
I mean
I don't understand many of the
renaissance paintings.
They don't mean to me,
they don't even look to me like they
look to the people who painted them
because I don't know the mythological
reference.
Even the Christian ones for that matter,
a lot of the paintings lost on me and
that's because
if we share a community that means our
unconscious presuppositions are
identical and so we can communicate at a
level where having those shared
presuppositions as implicitly accepted,
we can toss information back and forth
that like at the level of abstraction
where we don't yet agree.
I guess that must be the story.
Well,
if you and I are talking,
there's a whole bunch of things we're
not talking about that we already agree
about and so we don't have to talk about
them.
What we talk about are those things that
add a level of analysis where there's
still some dispute.
And I guess that as things become
increasingly beyond dispute,
they all go also get encoded farther
back down the hierarchy.
So
in this class for example,
we're not at each other's throats,
amber,
because,
and we don't ever argue about the
propriety of that.
It's,
it's so much accepted that it's not even
an issue.
There's no aggressive behavior.
It seems to me that part of this year
of,
uh,
of anomaly must come from a recognition
or an unconscious recognition perhaps of
human nature,
which is that,
uh,
exploration is intrinsically rewarding.
I mean,
would you agree that that is true?
It seems that
exploration for explorations sake seems
to be something that motivates people.
I mean,
and I noticed one of the things that
Tulsa,
I said was that Venus and his brothers,
they brought the strain chai idea of
home from school.
One of the first things he says is that
we were more than,
we're more than happy to entertain this
idea.
Right.
Why?
But simply because it's,
it's new.
Anything that's new is interesting.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
Well,
they were definitely interested in the
information.
Partly I think because it told them
something they already suspected.
So to some,
you know,
it was a receptivity.
Right?
Right.
The ground was busy that it's almost as
if it was an unarticulated experience.
Right?
Absolutely.
It provides a way of articulating and
that's the crystal hits the water.
Right?
But it doesn't put the experience there.
It articulates great.
Great.
As long.
Okay.
There's,
there's,
and you'll see this later in the
manuscript too,
um,
when Moses gets the rules,
the 10 commandments from God,
he's on the top of a mountain,
which is a standard place of
enlightenment when he comes to,
or illumination,
when he comes down the mountain,
his face is glowing so brightly that no
one can look at it.
Now what Moses did like he's,
let's assume for the present time that
if he is not a mythological figure,
he's at least a myth of sized historical
figure.
I mean the notion of the law giver is
fairly prevalent in archaic communities.
I mean the same role is played by Hammer
Hammer,
Rab die,
for example,
someone who codifies the law.
While the notion there is again,
like what Moses did basically could be
construed as having observed how
everyone behaved in essence anyways,
he codafide it,
right?
So he took information that existed at
the level of creative behavior,
imitation,
play,
ritual,
drought,
a myth,
religion and maybe even literature.
And he said,
well look,
this is what we're doing.
I can,
and the consequences that that appeared
as a revelation.
And I think part of the reason I'd be,
I'd be trying to figure,
because you do this in therapy too.
You say to someone,
look here,
here's a pattern of behavior.
First of all,
that in itself could be revelation.
You say the person says,
you know,
I've noticed myself doing that.
They're quite interested in that piece
of information.
I think the asset that's generated as a
consequence of encountering that sort of
information is partly due to
apprehension of all the possibilities
that are then revealed.
Like the more as you move information up
the hierarchy of abstraction,
the information becomes more and more
powerful,
which basically means that you can do
more with it with less work,
right?
That's why money is more powerful than
barter.
It's more abstract.
So that,
so it's more flexible and I think when
you move information up a level of
abstraction,
it produces a release of an effect
because you get an intimation of the
possibilities that are released as a
consequence of the increase in
abstraction.
I also think it's the case that if I can
tell you,
well look,
your story is such and such,
but you act this way and this is your
theory.
Well then you have the possibility of
moving those three levels of analysis
into an isomorphic arrangement so that
your north three people anymore,
one who act some way,
what do you have?
A badge is another way.
And one of the plans,
a third way.
You're one person who all of whose
efforts are devoted towards attaining,
we'll say,
man,
I also think that that's,
well,
that's,
that's the,
the utility of the integration.
And I think when one of the things that
we admire in people naturally,
I think is the consequence of the
unification of the operation of those
three systems,
which is to say,
who do you admire?
Well,
someone who doesn't say anything more
than is necessary,
so to speak,
and who acts out what they tell you.
Um,
I was about to say that I think at times
you're talking about positive ethic and
I think that how's it of apic works in
this direction if you're talking about
procedural as the outside and that
attraction towards the middle,
Andy,
because I think that,
um,
I think when you present,
once you have a level of abstraction,
the best way to present to somebody else
is not by,
by telling them,
but about presenting it in as
procedural.
They need as big a,
a circle as possible,
which is probably is,
which is probably more difficult to do.
Um,
well this sort of the okay information
that's behavioral anyways.
Yeah,
well that's Freud thought that merely
becoming conscious of something was
sufficient to bring about a cure or at
least at the early stages of his career,
but by the end he realized that unless
it had to be transformed from pure
conscious awareness back down to the
level of behavior did it,
you didn't know it.
Knowing it means that it's embodied.
I think that's the point that you're
making.
What Tulsa was doing is that he was
moving from abstraction maybe into
procedural and that produce negative
effect.
Yeah,
but it wouldn't be.
and this
I would say,
I would say that your interpretation is
accurate but that it wouldn't
necessarily have to produce negative
effect.
The problem is is the tolstoy encounter
that information and voluntarily was
sort of accidental in a sense.
He was walking along as it's a hell of a
piece of information for a 12 year old
school boy.
You know,
it's like it's a piece of information
that you can say in one sentence,
go on his dad.
That took like literally thousands of
years of concentrated effort and any
number of wars to produce and then you
can hand it to someone on a plate.
This is also part of the reason why are
this this,
this is kind of a leap,
but it makes it,
it's exactly the same sort of thing.
It's why a lot of foreign aid projects
don't work is because there's a lot more
information embedded in the things that
we distributed.
Then we think that there's a good
example,
um,
in the,
in the South Pacific islands,
the introduction of steel axis to the
stone age population devastated their
whole culture.
And part of it was missionary work.
But the thing is these colleges had
progressed to the point where if you are
at the top of the dominance hierarchy,
you had access to a stone ax and we
think about a stone ax,
you know,
who cares basically.
But when there aren't that many of them,
and when that's the thing that's the
hot,
the most technologically advanced
product you have still an ax is a symbol
of ultimate value as well as the stone
Max.
And when you distribute steel axes,
which the missionaries did relatively
indiscriminately,
it was very hard on the story that the
Pacific Islanders told cause you think,
what does that mean?
It's like,
okay,
it's a steel ax.
What's a steel ax for?
Well it's for cutting down trees and you
can do a better job with the steel ax
then you can with a stone ax.
But the thing is,
it's like Elvis Presley's guitar,
right?
Elvis Presley's guitar is just,
it's not just a thing to make music
with.
It's also Elvis Presley's guitar and it
steel ax is not just a thing to cut down
trees with its a cultural artifact that
has sort of embedded in it a whole bunch
of implicit messages,
partly about the relative power of two
cultures.
And in large part that it's like if you
have to work your whole life to get a
stone ax and then your four year old
child walks down the street and brings
home the steel ax,
this is going to be somewhat hard on
your,
on your,
uh,
on your frame of references.
Hey Dad,
the people down the street or getting
away machines that create money.
So anyways,
so when we introduce our artifacts into
alternative cultures,
we are putting a lot more into the
culture than we actually think because
the artifact,
it's like Marshall Mcluhan said the
medium is the message.
Artifact is something other than just
have to,
it has a story that's embedded in it.
So now you're tolstoy's case,
it's almost the artifact was rather a
story.
I mean it was,
yeah,
it was an idea crystallized that
experience that was already there.
Right?
Right.
Well,
yeah,
it was something,
it something abstract it up anyways,
so,
okay.
So anyways,
well normally seen information can come
in the form of a strange idea.
I guess what I was trying to do with
this with,
this is something I didn't really
recognize until this morning when I was
working on this stuff.
Again,
anomalous information can,
can enter your purview at every,
at any level of abstraction.
I guess that sort of leads is that
someone can,
if someone acts differently than you
act,
say,
well,
why does that bother you so much?
The beer.
Let's take the Germans for example,
prior to the Second World War.
Okay.
Their culture is a little unstable as
kind of dance,
very high rates and London,
terrible inflation and immense threat of
communism from the east and a nontrivial
threat.
I mean the communists took over Russia
after all.
So you know,
there's enough novelty,
enough normally floating around in the
air,
so to speak,
to make everyone perfectly well
uncomfortable.
Um,
under those circumstances,
anybody who acted differently with a
additional anomaly that I think it
appeared as pretty much as something
pretty much intolerable.
So
under normal circumstances,
it's possible that the alternative
behaviors of someone who's different
than you aren't doing the pose that much
of a problem to you,
but all you have to do is perturb the
system to some degree to make that sort
of anomalous information,
that much more intolerable state.
If someone's from a culture that's
different than you,
even if you don't talk to them and even
if they don't come into contact with you
that much,
the mere fact that there are around is
definitive evidence that a story that
isn't your story can be as success can
make someone as successful as you are or
perhaps even more successful.
Sometimes you can tolerate that and
sometimes you can't.
So anomalous information can come in the
form of pure procedure that's acted out
by someone else.
Sometimes that's not a problem but
sometimes it is
the final.
This is even less abstract.
I guess I wanted to read you something
cause I can't,
I can't make the argument is well is
that a road
page one 68
the question here is what can disrupt
you I guess and the things that can
disrupt the,
we can come in the form of direct
challenges,
indirect challenges to your cultural
structure and these are all things that
are other cultures basically agree
or sorry.
These two things are other cultures,
the stranger and the stranger.
This is schismatic movement within your
own culture and this is the unknown.
Doing its thing more or less all by
itself.
So cultures come to a halt.
Well,
let's say you're a culture.
This is a good example,
I suppose.
You raise goats.
So you have an agrarian culture.
The prime with goats is theirs that they
produce.
They produce environmental
transformations.
Goats like to live in deserts.
And the thing about guns is that if you
put them out somewhere soon,
what you have is a desert.
And the problem with deserts is that
they don't support that many goats.
So the point is,
is that if you have an adaptive
structure of one source,
the consequences of that adaptive
structure can be the transformation of
the environment in such a way so that
the adapter structure no longer no
longer works.
MMM.
Now this took me a long time to work out
because mythological representations of
the emergence of the negative unknown
are always contaminated with
mythological representations of the
tyranny of the known.
And it's almost as if from the
mythological perspective of it,
there's no difference between
the over dominance of this.
Yes.
And the emergence.
Oh.
And I thought,
how the hell could that be?
Why would that be?
Let me just read you something here.
The insufficiency of cultural adaptation
cannot easily distinguished from natural
catastrophe.
This society light on its feet,
so to speak,
is constantly in a position to adapt to
the unexpected,
even to the rapid and catastrophic kind
of expected,
even to transform such change into
something positively beneficial.
Likewise,
this means that that affect and
cognition earns more than with that.
I think it's a funny,
think about it this way.
Germany and Japan lost the Second World
War in England.
One,
you'd never know it now,
and that's partly because,
well,
it's part of it because the Americans in
a fit of historical anomaly,
it gave their enemies money instead of
killing the ball and their last
historically as lose to lose the war.
The United States,
the only country that ever really,
one of them were against us as Vietnam
and look where they are now.
Right?
Whereas you're looking at Japan and
Germany.
Well,
we made it.
It's the same.
It's a good example of of the Integra
relationship between this and this
because the Germans,
the Japanese underwent a catastrophe,
a sociological catastrophe.
Who's consequence was something very
beneficial in the final analysis.
Okay.
The point is is that
it's,
you can't necessarily distinguish the
valence of unexpected phenomenon from
the pattern of behavior that's
manifested in its presence,
which is to say that it's very difficult
to specify a particular situation that
is in and of itself negative
without any relationship to how you act
in the face of that thing.
So let me,
let me read you the,
you have to think about this from,
from the perspective of image,
myth and literature constantly represent
the parch kingdom.
This society victim on its most
frequently by drought,
which is the absence of water concretely
in the water of life or spirit.
Symbolically,
it scorched as a consequence of the over
prolonged the dominance of the ruling
idea,
this idea in the narrative and
frequently in there as well.
And he is the king,
the ancestral spirit representative of
his people made tyrannical by age or
pride,
unbearable disappointment or we're doing
under the influence of some malevolent
and advising force development of such
circumstances.
Call,
of course,
for the entrance of the hero who's the
lost son of the true king,
raised in secrecy by alternative
parrots,
the rightful ruler of the kingdom,
whose authority was undermine during
vulnerable youth or who had been
journeying in far off lands.
It was presumed yet here overturns the
tire and regains his proper place.
The gods please by the reestablishment
of the proper order,
a lot of the rain once more to fall and
the story of this type,
the creative aspect of the unknown or
nature is locked away metaphorically by
the totalitarian.
No opinion of the current culture such a
state of affairs might be represented.
For example,
by the sleeping princess in the kingdom
brought to a standstill.
What by some alternative variant of the
existence of the treasure,
hard to attain paralyzed by patriarchal
despotism or frequently by fear of the
terrible mother kingdom remained
stagnant while the princess nature and
your benevolent guys waits for the kiss
of the hero two week her awakened and
revitalize beauty.
Subsequently we animate,
sir.
Yeah.
See these stories basically say that if
the unknown,
if the environment is turn,
if the environment has turned against
you,
kill the king.
Okay.
Because whether you know it or know him,
he's a tyrant.
And so from the mythological
perspective,
there's no such thing as the negative
aspect of the unknown as such.
It's always only maybe it in
relationship to a ruling idea.
And the mythological idea is that if
it's negative,
there's something wrong with it.
We wouldn't idea.
That's the basic notion.
It's a strange idea.
And let's be honest,
obviously the circling the wagons,
sorry.
Do you have to elaborate on like,
like,
uh,
becoming more rigidly holding onto you,
right.
When facebook,
it's not precisely the,
it's not precisely the officer because,
okay.
And then I'll,
I'll get,
I'll get back to this.
If the,
if the environment has become,
has turned against you,
then that's a sign that it's time to
sacrifice the cake because
this,
the unknown is only negative in
relationship to an idea.
We already know that.
Right?
I mean,
that's what we've been talking about
with regards to the structure of these
stories.
All lawns that you construe the
motivation valence of something with
respect to your current story.
So the mythological story basically says
if negative things are happening all
around you,
it's not the environment as an objective
thing.
There's something wrong with the way
you're living.
That's why well say in an archaic exists
in an archaic society.
It's actually frequently happen is if
things aren't working out,
like there's a foot long drought,
it's time to kill the king.
When you think about a stupid idea that
is,
you know,
they quit,
the Kale is the king has to do with the
drug.
But the point is,
the point of the story is that the
environment in large part is the
consequence of your adaptive response.
It's a presence,
at least in terms of its valence.
So it's a very intelligent to kill the
cane when things aren't going well
because after all,
the king is the pattern of behavior that
constitutes the kingdom.
And if the kingdom isn't going very
well,
which means that the negative space of
the great mother is constantly a very
well.
And who do you sacrifice when you
sacrifice them to the grapevine?
Right.
In hopes that her causative facebook
reappeared.
And the funny thing is it works.
This is another,
this isn't,
again,
that's like you,
you people are going to have to evaluate
these ideas over a longer time,
I suspect.
But I'll tell you,
I've never read anything anywhere that
explains why people engaged in
sacrificial rituals.
It's nothing that ever made any sense to
me,
although people did it all.
So this makes sense.
It's ridiculous.
The thing that people
participate in activities like that in
so many places over such long periods of
time for no reason whatsoever.
Well this is not ideally interact.
You know,
cause like if what you're doing isn't
working,
kill it,
do something else.
Good thinking.
So I don't understand why you'd have the
why in that diagram,
you know,
where are the opposite each other?
Well,
it's the positive aspect of our culture
that protects you from the negative
aspect of it.
But it was like snacks.
Yes,
that's right.
They're stacked discs.
That's right.
It would be better if you had to do four
more faces so that they are,
the positive aspects of the Cape
couldn't line up with the positive
aspect.
And so
because in that case you'll have to
shoot him if he'll sketch that or
appreciate because I know the right,
there's something like there's something
missing,
just a receipt where the
indicating king where the negative
sinus.
Yeah.
We'll just make it a go
here
where the no weekend and also,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I don't know either.
Thinking about
the idea that since there are stack
this,
the uh,
the known blocks you from the,
yeah,
but that's still works,
right,
because this is still inscribed inside
the circle.
So then this,
right?
Yes.
No.
Well,
but then you have them,
you don't have the positive,
I mean,
if it's,
if it's not something that works by
blocking,
then you have the positive aspect of the
known you.
Oh,
right,
right.
Positive aspect of the unknown,
which is what,
and the other way to help them there.
But yeah,
right.
The negative because the negative of the
negative of the,
but that's true.
They're more blacks.
The positive.
This is true too though because they say
that good is the enemy of the better,
which is to say that you know,
well
you don't want a divorce,
you had keyboard is,
well a divorce you might keep the
keyboard on,
a computer is laid out so that you can
type slowly.
And the reason for that is because it
was designed on a for a manual type
partner and really fast typists with jam
and the keys.
So some bright character figured out how
to separate the most commonly used keys.
So that really fast type is good and Jim
and manual type Rick horshack keyboard
where the key is that use most are laid
out very close to each other and you
hardly have to move your fingers at all.
Now I would like to,
I'd like to learn to use it,
divorce,
Shaq keyboard,
but I already know how to use the qwerty
keyboard.
So I don't,
and that means that what I know stops me
from learning something because what I
know is good enough,
it stops me from learning something
better.
So I'm off to say,
I mean I see your objection.
It makes sense.
It's sometimes it's hard to make the
jump.
Not saying that it's wrong,
I'm just saying that there's sort of
mixing the metaphor of blocking with the
metaphor of,
of revealing.
Right,
right,
right.
Well yeah,
I'll have to keep this in mind and see
if there's a way of balancing both.
So then we're,
the reaction to threat in the
environment is to clean.
You are rigidly to the kid as opposed to
kill the kid.
Right now it would be the negative,
negative,
I don't know.
Yes,
that's right.
I see what you mean.
Yeah,
that's exactly what happens.
Good short term solution.
But no walk in the long term cause
damage to your father.
You know,
all you're doing is accumulating is knew
what you're doing is like here's a whole
bunch of disasters.
You can have them one at a time,
over a long span of time or you can
shove them all into a clump out there in
the future and go along merrily until
you fall into them and have them all at
once.
Right.
So,
and that's basically the,
that's the authoritarian answer to the
problem,
right?
That may certainly the way that's right.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
But one of the things I want to make
more clear in the second half of this
manuscript,
which isn't very well laid out right
now,
it's that there are three patterns of
response to a normal.
One is face it and do something about
it,
which is basically admitted there,
number one,
and then engage in whatever modification
of your story is necessary to produce
something positive from your encounter
with it.
The second one is circle the wagons,
which is to say some anomaly is facing
me from outside.
I'm afraid of the known because I've
sacrificed my relationship with the
hero.
That's what an authoritarian does.
I'm not creative like the emperor's
creative for me,
I just do what he says.
When you circle the wagons,
you also restrict the amount of novelty
that exists within your constricted
environment and dampen down your aspect,
act as a consequence,
right?
Because you make everyone the same,
which is what authoritarians too.
So that's one way of going about it.
Wrong.
The other way of going about it wrong is
it supposed to be the king is dead long
live the king.
The wrong way of going about it is the
king is dead period,
period and people are motivated to do
that.
That's the thing.
It's like you'd say,
why the hell would someone do that?
Because we already know that you need
the king around or you're flooded with
anxiety,
so why kill him?
While the thing is people do that,
you know that's that artistic or
rebellious sort of sort of style of
adaptation.
But the problem with having a king is
that you have to do what he says and
that's the price you pay for your
security.
You might be willing to get rid them if
you can't stand any responsibility.
And that's the,
that's the alternative,
improper mode that a patient,
I think that's where you get this right
in Chinese medicine there order
and chaos and if you're ill it's because
you have too much yin and Yang or you
have too much Yang.
You note about the end and the job that
the Chinese doctor is to analyze you,
so to speak,
to ensure that the balance between the
two phenomena is optimal,
which means that you're here instead of
over here in the authoritarian zone of
the world are over here in the chaotic
zone.
Okay,
so next week we start talking about
this.
The final part of the story,
which is
this,
which is I'm interested in you see,
as we know,
we know that you have a very good reason
for protecting your culture,
which is that it regulates your
emotions.
What I'm interested in is given that
it's necessary for you to maintain your
culture,
even in the face of threats from other
cultures,
are there patterns of personal behavior
that amplify it's are there patterns of
personal behavior and amplified the
danger of culture and patterns of
behavior that reduce it?
So is there something about your
relationship to your culture that can
either exacerbate intrinsic problems of
group identification or reduce them?
And that's what we're going to try to
find out in the last part of the course.
It's like culture's necessary.
The problem with the necessity of
culture is that it virtually ensures the
existence of conflict.
Given that,
is there a way to act to make it worse
or to make it better,
and that's what we're going to talk
so.